Maya Angelou has a great quote in the
space she says something around you
might not remember where you were or
what you were doing but you're always
going to remember how you felt that is
the epitome of experience we want to
elevate how you're feeling
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret chord Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
this episode is all about trust and we
have two very very special guests to
talk to us about four factors of trust
Ashley reichelt is a principal at
Deloitte digital works with clients
across Industries to help them to
reimagine their brands and experiences
she believes that building trust is the
single greatest opportunity to create
competitive Advantage so she created HX
trust idtm a groundbreaking measurement
tool poised to become the gold standard
for evaluating organizational
performance to help companies measure
predict and build trust with their
customers Workforce and partners
Ashley's research and compelling points
of view have appeared in such Outlets as
Wall Street Journal adweek and CMS wire
she is the author of the four factors of
trust with Amelia Dunlop Emilia is the
chief experience officer at Deloitte
digital and a principal at Deloitte LLP
helps organizations solve their toughest
problems using human equity center
design to build empathy and Trust Amelia
believes in elevating the experience for
all humans including customers workers
and partners she received Consulting
Magazine's 2020 top women in technology
award for excellence and Innovation she
is the author of The Wall Street Journal
bestseller elevating The Human
Experience three paths to loves to love
and worth at work and co-author of the
four factors of trust with Ashley
Reichel Amelia's research and thought
leadership on elevating The Human
Experience have appeared in such Outlets
as Wall Street Journal Forbes MIT
technology review entrepreneur Inc and
New York Post
Amelia Dunlop Ashley ragtailed welcome
to 20 minute leaders thank you so much
for being here the two of you at the
same time how are you
doing great good morning oh it's doing
great I'm very very happy to have both
of you here co-authors of the four
factors of trust and and we'll get into
that book and pretty soon and um and
it's very special to have both of you
here at the same time generally
um this show is only with one guest so
here I have a double the double the fun
and we get to talk a lot about building
trust and and a cool part of the story
which I'm excited to hear about and I'm
very curious about it is sort of the
formation of trust that was formed
between the two of you and and how and
through maybe the story of the
collaboration on the book and there's a
lot of correlation with the actual
contents of of the book and as I'd love
to to First hear a little bit about each
of your experiences leading up to this
collaboration and then we'll get talking
about trust through your friendship so
so Amelia I wanted to you know start on
them actually I'd love to for you to
continue
sure well let me just introduce myself
um so great to be here Michael thank you
for having us I'm the chief experience
officer at Deloitte digital
um and I could tell you a little bit
about
um how Ashley and I came to write this
book
um she and I were both part of the a
leadership team here that a set of
aspirations to elevate The Human
Experience a number of years ago and we
realized you can't Elevate anything if
people don't trust you
um and so that kind of began that
Journey
um and it's also no surprise that to our
team members that it started out you
know a bit of a rocky relationship and
actually Ashley Ashley and I had to work
uh quite a lot on what it meant to build
trust with each other
um and that's a lot of what led to the
writing of this book so Ashley do you
want to jump in yep Ashley Reichel
um in Massachusetts just west of Boston
and I've been helping clients to
reimagine experiences for oh the past 20
years Amelia and I began as she
mentioned thinking about experience of
gosh what was that Amelia four or five
years ago yeah and then as we started
digging in really needed to understand
how we could help companies better break
down what drives or erodes trust in
order to better Elevate human
experiences which is how we came up with
the four factors
so elevating Human Experience what does
that really mean dumb in the world we
expand on that a little bit what does
that mean it sounds awesome I just
really want to understand
awesome well actually it is the title of
my my last book Michael so it's I
already Name an experience uh three
paths to love and worth at work but it's
essentially you know it means uh we all
have asparagus uh no matter no matter
what we do but how can we be intentional
about making them just a little bit
better for your customers your Workforce
and also for your partners
um and it's it's a passion that Ashley
and I share
um because it's you know makes the kind
of organizations we want to be a part of
and the kind of world we want to live in
Michael Maya Angelou has a great quote
in the space she says something around
you might not remember where you were or
what you were doing but you're always
going to remember how you felt that is
the epitome of experience we want to
elevate how you're feeling
interesting okay so take me into your
own into your own journey of of building
trust and then and then we'll connect it
back to ultimately the the four factors
and and elevating human experience as
Amelia mentioned I think we probably had
a rocky start we weren't
um Familia and I had a little bit of a
rocky start ourselves we you know
clearly thought the other one was
capable and reliable but we weren't
always on the same page in terms of the
other factors I am an early morning
person and love to get up and dash off
emails and texts that doesn't that's not
Amelia's style at all so she she was
adapting partly to that and
um Amelia how would you describe
adapting to my style
well I think for us it was demonstrating
Humanity to each other recognizing that
we were both capable leaders but we we
had different styles and ways of
interacting and I think in addition to
demonstrating the humanity and empathy
there's transparency which sort of makes
you kind of you know your beliefs and
your context more uh present to another
but even before they ask and I think the
combination of humanity and transparency
really is what helped us kind of uh
build you know it's a really strong
relationship you know and Michael one of
one of the funny facts is um there's a
you know a woman who's part of our
marketing team told us that she's worked
with many co-authors on many books uh
and typically by the by this point in
the process with the book about to
launch they're not actually talking to
each other
you know a lot of time together every
day
um we also wrote this book entirely on
zoo together during wow
um and um have had you know a great uh
sort of time kind of building our
relationship
anything our relationship is only
strengthened which is great
that's awesome that's real that's really
awesome okay so soon we're gonna dive
into the four factors of trust and and
what enabled your relationship to to
grow is there you know through through
this experience that that what I'm
hearing is uh and a lot of times and
results in a different scenario
um but why is trust even something that
is so meaningful for us to even be
discussing so obviously you know we all
we all agree that trust is important but
why should Business Leaders you know
innovators entrepreneurs you know really
anybody consider
the thinking process of creating
information of trust to be something
that they need to even engage with as a
thought experiment for themselves and
not take it trivially or just
experimentally why is this something so
so important
that's a great question because I think
we all know intuitively that you have to
have trust right we haven't sat down
with any Executives who said no trust
isn't important but articulating why it
matters is I think what helps people to
understand why it why we need to build
it and that's because trust in and of
itself is what really drives people's
behavior when you break it down on the
customer side people are 90 if people
trust a brand they're 90 get more likely
to buy it again and 62 percent of those
customers are going to be loyal on the
Walker side eighty percent of workers
who highly trust their employer are
motivated to work versus just 30 who
aren't and of those 63 aren't going to
be looking for other jobs they also have
longer tenure higher satisfaction with a
salary the list goes on and on so we
know trust drives the behaviors that
people want to see we also know that
trust in and of itself is super
difficult to describe when you ask
somebody do you trust me it's really
hard to answer that question do you
trust me to what do you trust me to show
up on time do you trust me to have your
back what does that actually mean that's
why we tried to break it down into the
component pieces and parts that help
companies to understand what drives
trust why they're trusted or not and you
actually
um you created HX trust idtm tell me
about that because it sounds when I'm
saying it's a measurement tool to to
evaluating organizational performance
And in regards to building trust how do
you then more actively and proactively
in you know measure Trust on it on a
standardized scale when it's so
subjective
so we break down trust into the four
factors that drive it we actually did a
ton of research to try to understand
both what resources have already looked
at as well as in our own research what
drives trust and what our research told
us was that there are four things that
do humanity and transparency describe an
organization or a Brand's promise am I
making you a good promise capability and
reliability describe a companies or
Brand's ability to deliver on that
promise
trust is built when you make a good make
and keep good promises which is actually
what the four factors describe
yeah and Michael would I jump in and
shared back to your question around the
importance of trust
um trust is really important and you
really notice it when you don't have it
and when it's lost and we also know that
uh trust has actually been declining in
the last 40 years across every
institution and whether it's
um governments and medical professionals
businesses so it's one of the reasons
we're really passionate about this topic
is we need to do a better job of
building trust with each other and and
across different Industries and the
other thing that we realized is we need
a new measure of trust because the
existing measures are all kind of rear
view mirrors right they're going to
after a breakdown or trust incidents
after the fact but we as Leaders wanted
something that helped us predict
behaviors so that we can proactively
build not just trust but the kind of
kind of experiences that make people
better off
okay so let's dive into into these um
these four factors a little bit more and
and where do we see in the world these
four factors coming into play either
positively or negatively so how I'm I'd
love to make this surreal for for what
we're actually observing in the world
around us
Amelia do you want to take a crack at
the four factors and I can give some
examples of where we're seeing the
Manifest yeah sure so um yeah so as
Ashley already said that the four
factors capability and reliability and
Humanity
um and one of the things that we noticed
is we had a hypothesis when we did our
research
um that that Humanity would really
matter uh and driving uh kind of
customer behavior in particular but like
one of the things we observed in the
research was that that just wasn't so
um that that capability and reliability
really mattered um and the example we
often give is you and I wouldn't go to a
restaurant uh that didn't uh serve you
know high quality food and kind of we
knew that would kind of would be so safe
and not make us sick but in our research
we're 280 more likely to go back to that
restaurant if they treat us with
humanity and transparency and so that's
you know the example of
um you know being being clear with us
about why our food might be late or why
they might be short staffed
um you know break out that birthday
candle for your kid these are the kinds
of things is both humanity and
transparency that drive
um the likelihood to return
um and kind of loyal Behavior
and when you look at the companies that
are doing well the we broke these down
into several archetypes the top trusted
companies the ones that do the best are
the ones that out deliver on all four
factors so not just the capability
reliability which are kind of table
Stakes they get you in the door but who
um exceed with humanity and tell you
what you need to know a great example of
that would be Marriott as an example and
one of the most poignant member memories
I have of Marriott over the last couple
of years was when Arne Sorensen came on
and made a video for employees and
customers to talk about what the
pandemic was going to do and how they
were going to get through it and it was
um as transparent as you get he was
suffering from cancer at the time and
had a shaved head and his team was
worried about what that might look like
or mean for the people who are watching
it and instead of instead of
communicating anxiety it actually
communicated a real level of humanity
and transparency he talked about being
in this together and that is how Mary it
operates and there I've really good
example of one of the most trusted
amazing from a Leader's perspective
how I assume that not only these traits
are ones that should be that would
Elevate an organization but it is
probably also relevant for for
individual leaders within organizations
right on in the relationships of forming
and the the way that they're succeeding
as leaders in the organizations
how how so how true is that that these
are also similar traits for yeah I mean
one of the things that that we like is
that we wanted to create something that
was useful for all leaders right so you
don't have to wait or uh you know higher
ups in your organization to do something
uh you as an individual can kind of
demonstrate these four factors in your
organization and then that helps kind of
grow that experience for your team for
your organization or for your customers
so Ash do you want to talk about your
own personal leadership philosophy sure
that's well said even if you can't
measure trust as an organization you can
certainly aspire to to live those
characteristics yourself and I try to I
actually share my leadership philosophy
with my team I try to be human so to
cultivate an inclusive practice where we
demonstrate empathy and kindness I focus
on transparency I spent um the better
part of a decade living in Holland and
they have a word that's break behind
which basically translates to everything
can and should be talked about so I try
to share with my teams what they need to
know and then of course you have to be
capable and reliable to really really do
a good job now Amelia actually has a
practice which I think especially
demonstrates Humanity Amelia do you want
to talk about your Wednesday notes sure
so Michael in the middle of that
pandemic I found that on Wednesdays were
the hardest to get through right you
were you were the most days from
probably ever seeing you know someone uh
another human being in person
um and he had a long stretch still to go
until the next weekend
um and so I started this practice of of
calling Wednesday's Joy day and writing
a personal note to the entire team
sharing with gratitude what brought me
joy and you know and I remember there in
the early days Joy would be just you
know a bag of bag of M Ms that I would
share with my three kids who are also no
school um in our house and just you know
the Delight on their faces to like
whatever my daughter's saying wait where
did you get this it's like I'm an adult
I could buy candy in the middle of the
day but I shared that Joy with our team
and then what they did Michael is they
would write write in their stories and
so this is where you know we met lots of
puppies we celebrated birthdays
virtually
um and just this idea that Wednesdays
are Joy day um to kind of bring the kind
of the humanity it also kind of reached
through that
um that divide right where we're really
able to connect to delay but to share
just a little extra Humanity
incredible so what I'd love to also take
away from here and selfish request for
me as a hopefully an upcoming leader
what in your opinion
in early opinions are some things that
that a young entrepreneur business
leader
whatever they what what can we do
actionably starting today to generate
more trust within ourselves within our
colleagues the people that we are that
we are and leading or we are being led
by us how what what changes do you
identify can we make that are not
necessarily trivial or intuitive to help
Elevate the experience that we're
providing to the people around us
well in our data one of the factors that
most companies Miss is transparency one
of the definitions you might hear about
trust is it's when you make yourself
vulnerable for somebody that's when you
start to build trust and it's a
demonstration of trust of making myself
vulnerable to you and trusting you to to
be kind or to treat that well we think
that the way companies demonstrate
vulnerability is actually by being
transparent sharing the kinds of
information that you need to know in
order to make a decision I would be
cautious by the way of saying
transparency doesn't mean everything
this doesn't mean the 500 page legal
brief that you need about how we're
going to use your data but it does mean
sharing information in a way that's
easily digestible and understandable
Amelia and I have a metaphor that we use
Amelia talked about picking restaurants
that are capable and reliable in places
where they have food you want to eat and
you know you're going to not get food
poisoning well let's say you go to Farm
to Table Restaurant it's really exciting
to get to know where the food comes from
who the farmer was what how he or she
grows or what their family does on the
farm you probably don't want to know
though what animal you're eating or how
the animal is possessed so relevant
transparency is a is a pretty big one
Amelia what would you add well I think
your question is very practical and
Michael which is what can your listener
take away and and the way I think about
it is when we did the research on what
really drives trust and what we as
Leaders can do we learned that the four
factors are productive of you know 74 of
behavior which as a social scientist
like that's pretty incredible and so
what I would say is start being really
intentional about how you're living the
four factors what are you doing to
demonstrate capability reliability in
your own practice how are you kind of
bringing Humanity to your teams and to
your customers and just like Ashley said
how are you doing it in a way that's
transparent in a way that's relevant so
I think we could each take something
away to kind of build trust in our
relationships and then obviously start
to measure and predict and act on trust
at the scale of your organization and
just to quantify what Amelia's talking
about let me make this connection so
when a company is trusted or has a high
degree of humanity
customers are 280 percent more likely to
stick with that brand during a mistake
we're actually working with an airline
company right now and I'll give you a
live example of how this is playing out
awesome summer was a pretty tough time
for Airlines right there are a ton of
delays people all coming back to
traveling for this particular Airline
client when they had a customer who
trusted them and that customer was
delayed we saw Zero impact on their
scores however when they had a customer
that didn't trust them to begin with and
then they were delayed we saw a negative
25 hit to their score basically what
you're seeing is you know people who are
traveling say yeah and they trust you to
say oh no the airline is probably doing
everything it can delays happen it's
just the way it goes whereas somebody
who doesn't trust is saying okay did you
did your crew time out did you give my
plane to somebody else what's really
going on here so the trust really does
Drive Behavior
well
and so many more questions that I have
it says
yeah I don't think I just want that is
um as you could probably tell and I know
you do as well Michael like we care
really passionately about trust but it's
not just to build it in and of itself
um it is all about what it enables you
to do and one of the things we were also
excited about in the research is that
those companies that are most trusted
outperform their peers by up to 400
percent so it's actually a competitive
advantage that we're really excited
about
yeah I mean again and then it has to
translate to something that you can
really you know be data driven about and
measure otherwise in in such a
fast-paced world where
um people are racing and things that
aren't aligned directly with the kpis
that they're being measured for it's
it's hard to to start a conversation
around and it sounds like and and I'm
definitely excited to read myself and
the four factors but it sounds like
you've you've you've taken something
that is very subjective and very he
sometimes feels a little bit theoretical
and and turned it into something that's
very actionable and very very data
driven measurable so that people can
actually see how how the why this is
something that they need to be to be
putting a large priority on and so I
really appreciate this time that the
both of you it gave me and I'm I'm
really excited to to read the book and
to become a better leader myself through
it and um and so thank you very very
much for being here and this was
wonderful and continue you know helping
amazing organizations be be better
involved better trust elevating The
Human Experience ultimately and thank
you very very much
thanks for having us it was a lot of fun
yep great to be here thank you thank you
[Music]